really most importantly is a win for
consumers because we've been contending
that energy labels are misleading
because they're tested on vacuum
cleaners that have no dirt in them and
when you and I use one that's what
they're there for
and so we're rather pleased yes but is
it actually a win for consumers because
this case now goes back to the original
court and you may lose again well you
have a point so this is the second round
of an installation and it goes back to
the law courts and it'll take time and
and so it'll take some time for all of
this to play out but nevertheless I
think is important to see that the court
has affirmed what makes logical sense
that testing should be as close to real
life conditions as possible how does
what the situation is like in Europe
compared with the rest of the world well
you know Europe has made a bit of a mess
of this because you know those energy
labels are confusing and in the rest of
the world largely there are no energy
labels and and so it's a you know really
a moot point in result or you clearly
believe that the European Commission was
somehow being swayed by your competitors
well think of it that way if you make a
bagged vacuum cleaner than the challenge
you have is that the moment that bagged
vacuum cleaner takes dust in it starts
losing suction and so it stands to
reason that it's rather advantageous to
test a vacuum cleaner that takes no dust
in and thus is clean and if you look at
the continental European manufacturers
they all make bagged vacuum cleaners and
of course James invented bagless and
cyclonic vacuum cleaner technology and
so we are the odd man out clearly so
James Dyson was a campaigner for leave
do you think this ruling is going to
make him feel any more warmly about the
European Court of Justice well I don't
know that but I think what's most
important is that we're really standing
up for consumers we're just trying to
make sure that you know when you go into
a shop and you look at a box that you
know what is being claimed is what you
get and then you can make your choice
and all is good I'm not a bad Consumer
Sentiment Jen
really in the UK the moment I mean there
are a lot of concerns that consumer
spending is going to go off a cliff are
you seeing any softening in spending yet
no we're doing quite well and in fact
we're doing very well around the world
and and you know most importantly we're
investing in our future so we've just
opened or acquired another technology
side well having tonight gives us 500
acres of space to build another
technology campus and in fact this week
we've accepted the first 26 applications
of students that will be at Dyson
University at our Institute of
Technology so that's what really excite
us technology products and investing in
that future how is the UK leaving the
going to affect your business do you
regard it as a positive we're not really
focused on that in many ways because
we're about technology and we're very
very global and you know we have 42
nationalities working our technology
campus and mums buri and you know we're
in 75 countries in the world and if
anything we believe there are
opportunities for us to do more in other
places and in fact James was in India
with the Prime Minister you know to
announce our plans of opening Dyson for
business in India and so you know were
were seeking opportunities and seeking
growth and seeking technology